la France a briller lors de ces Mondiaux
de parasyclisme sur piste 2022 à
domicile dans ce bloodrome national de
50 ans en Yvelines et tricolore emporté
17 médailles pendant les quatre jours de
compétition les Bleus terminent 3e au
tableau des médailles en terme de
performance sportive les athlètes ont
bien répondu présent et on a de
nombreuses médailles après la deuxième
satisfaction c'est qu'il y avait trois
quatre jeunes
dont on attendait pas ce parcours sur
ces championnats et qui ont prouvé que
2028 c'était pour eux un peu trop loin
et qu'il voulait avancer un peu plus
vite que prévu côté bleu la star de ces
championnats du monde restera Alexandre
léotté ce jeune français de 22 ans
termine ses mondiaux avec un bilan de 4
médailles d'or une médaille d'argent et
des records du monde ce dimanche le
pista remporte notamment l’omnium et le
15 km scratch j'avais beaucoup bossé
j'ai
amélioré beaucoup de choses dans mon
quotidien aussi pour que ça fonctionne
le mieux possible et je vois que ça
fonctionne et que le fait de souffrir à
l'entraînement ça paye donc je suis très
content une sportive local c'est
également distingué Christelle Ribaut
termine 3e du scratch 10 km en catégorie
C2 j'ai vraiment heureuse vraiment comme
je disais c'est c'est une médaille de
bronze mais qui vaut de l'or par rapport
à tous mes efforts consentis depuis
quelques années c'est une belle
récompense surtout chez moi à la maison
devant devant ma famille mes proches mes
amis et sur le lieu dont où je où je
coach aussi toute la semaine parce que
je travaille aussi ici au Vélodrome tout
ce beau monde se retrouvera dans moins
de 2 ans à l'occasion des Jeux
paralympiques de Paris l'événement se
déroulera du 28 août au 8 septembre 2024